a man that really wants a feminine woman
will bring the feminine woman out of
America
no that's so true oh my gosh this is
stupid
thought to me it was like what are you
talking about yeah they're very
disagreeable and they take on that like
dominant role I'm so masculine you're so
scared of me I don't know
you know and I also with the pregnancy I
don't think it's equal fault I think
it's more on the woman than the man why
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
Series where I read pill women
um if you don't know I show women that
have never seen red pill content red
pill content um so welcome to the show
introduce yourself to the people hello
everyone my name is Sophia I'm
originally from the Gold Coast in
Australia and now I live in London I'm a
dancer and I do social media so give
them your Instagram you know while
you're at it my Instagram is Sophia K
Kate which is actually so today I'm
going to show you whatever podcast this
is kind of another version of what we do
here um I would say I I do a bit more a
mix of red pill and conservative but
they're just straight
um pull up pull up the footage
yeah I've been on this I'll show you one
of these days I'll show you when I was
on yeah a guy who's a doctor a guy who's
just making a ton of money he'll date a
girl who works at McDonald's a woman
who's an attorney a female doctor she's
not gonna date a guy
for this never yeah so she's hiring the
thing is is that as as Men start to make
more money typically their pool their
options their pool opens up whereas as
as women start becoming higher earners
actually their pool starts to shrink I
think that's true yes yeah I agree
what if their money
like is often they don't make that much
money in the corporate business plan
they were always always The Breadwinner
don't matter so it's like of course it
doesn't matter to you because it's never
been oh we need women to have money so
that we can date them like it's never
been a thing but for a woman the man was
supposed to be the provider back in the
day like she was looking for someone to
take care of her so of course a woman's
gonna think like that yes because that's
yeah exactly you mentioned instinctively
but but but the issue is we can't have
both and what women want is they want a
traditional outcome but we want a modern
lifestyle so the issue is we're saying
hey we want to work too we want to earn
money too which is fine go do that but
the issue is you cannot then say I want
a traditional man I mean you can't ask
for it but the odds are you're not going
to get it which is why women with
master's degrees women
um that have really I mean look at all
the successful women in careers Kim
Kardashian's divorce three times Oprah
has no children like usually there are
exceptions that have done it but usually
it comes at a cost so yeah okay that's
you're 100 correct it's Evolution
because as we evolved men were the we
did provisioning we were the providers
we did provisioning we did protection so
it's sort of there's a biology you guys
are forced into doing that what's that
y'all definitely might have been forced
into doing that I mean I think you have
to do that right but you're saying
you're being forced to provide for a
woman no we are extinctively wanting I
think some men well I think some men
want to do it and some don't well I
think men are sick of paying for women
that aren't traditional yeah so it's
like um you know do you know what
percent of women were virgins on their
wedding night 100 years ago no 85 yeah I
know I know well yeah now now men pray
for a woman that hasn't slept with more
than five men you realize in all in all
human history sleeping with five men was
so bad that like you would have been a
absolute yeah so when I say modern women
or horse I mean it because it from like
it doesn't change it's because we're in
a modern time it doesn't change biology
and it does it doesn't like did you know
when you sleep with more than five men
you only have a 20 chance of being
happily married if you're a virgin you
have an 80 chance of being happily
married I know but like if women knew
that at like 15 14 years old I mean I
got women are starting so young I guess
12. yeah like 10 now probably at this
point it's like don't like I mean I I
think I probably would have like maybe
moved differently too if I knew if if
I'm a virgin I have an 80 chance of
being happily married yeah I think I I
literally did it literally two three
weeks before I turned 18. the only
reason as well my sister so I was like
oh Sophia you need to do it before at
least 18. oh your sister said that to
you yeah that's horrible I was like come
on now but now then I was like okay well
maybe I should then no but this is the
problem as women like on an innate level
I'll tell you why women do this they
give you bad advice yeah because it on
an evolutionary level even your sister
who I'm sure you love yeah it's they're
the you're a sexual competition to her
yeah and they might not be like a reason
like um it might not be uh conscious
like I'm not saying she knows this but
on an innate level she's trying like I'm
guessing what she five years older than
you no she's 14 years older 14. okay
well that makes even more sense the
bigger the age yeah no because because
you you um married yes and she's got
three kids oh why would you do that but
at that time she was single no she was
still married but she only had no she
thinks she had two kids just I don't
know why okay I don't know what she was
doing but I don't know neither but I'll
tell you why in an evolutionary it's
because like they want if you have slept
with more people you're less valuable to
men yeah and I understand that so but so
that's why women will encourage [__]
Behavior yeah but then why is it the
same with like men men will do the exact
same and they'll get be shamed it makes
them more valuable because again it
doesn't it a man that sleeps with a lot
of women is more valuable a woman that
sleeps with a lot of men is less
valuable why because we don't change our
biology so if a woman had slept with
multiple men historically he doesn't
know if the kids are his so there's and
they're hardwiring their DNA they want
to make sure I know that child is mine
and it's the same reason like what you
don't want a wife and a mother that you
know has all these exes that they're
like they can make fun of the kids about
you know if she slept with all these
people that's the one thing yeah but
then the guy got the girl pregnant oh
right right the guy did get the girl
pregnant
because Hegel had pregnant he could have
used protection well saved it well I I
think I was asked answering a different
question we could go into pregnancy too
but the question I was trying to answer
was that the reason that men um the
reason there's a difference between
sleeping around for men and for women is
because the women won't pick men that
get lots of women because historically
that meant he could protect and provide
for you because other women picked him
where historically the women if she was
if she was he doesn't know that the kid
is his so that's why men are repulsed by
women that have slept around like they
can't really help it it's like repulsive
to them yeah and so even like the men
that will tell you they don't care
they're kind of lying because they just
want to add a body right they're like
yeah and they're not gonna marry you but
that but the thing is like the men that
actually want to get married which is
few and far between you say the men they
don't really want to get married right
for good reason and I could go into that
in a different day but you know and I
also with the pregnancy I don't think
it's equal fault I think it's more on
the woman than the man why okay because
if you don't want to get pregnant if you
want to have sex and not get pregnant
yeah so I I'll use me right I can go to
the doctor and get an IUD right I can go
to the doctor and get birth control I
know they have that thing they put in
your arm I know these come with side
effects but that's a choice right yeah I
can also choose to wait till I'm married
so I could abstain from sex and say I'm
not going to have sex until I'm married
yeah I can also require that the men
that sleep with me have condoms on which
they surveyed women 50 only 50 percent
of women require a condom with a new
partner so half of women no condom
anyways yeah I know right right yeah so
so I that's that's another
um thing that I can do yeah next I can
can also take a plan B after if I want
yes I can also go to the doctor and get
an abortion yeah I can also have the kid
and give it up for adoption yeah if he
wants to we shouldn't do that well
depending on the circumstance well I
mean I would keep it because I believe
in responsibility but you can right
either so many couples that want to
adopt I don't even think it's like
completely irresponsible no
um or I can say hey to the dad can you
raise the kid because I just don't think
I'm capable of it so I have I have nine
options now the man yeah correct so he
doesn't know if you're on birth control
or not but you should tell him if you
were respectful well I'll tell you a
problem is a lot of women lie right yeah
yeah you're not wrong right it's so the
condom is an equal consent thing so we
both not using a condom is equally
irresponsible yes because we both agree
or not it's not just him putting it on
you could you could say put on it right
yeah that that part's equal yeah but the
part that's not equals after the
pregnancy happens or after the sex
happens I he cannot make you take the
plan B he cannot make you give an
abortion he cannot make you give the kid
up for adoption now it's a hundred
percent your choice so I think when it
comes to the kids that are born I think
it's more on the women than the men
because the man has one option that the
woman also has an equal option of so
every choice the man has the woman has
an equal choice but every choice the
woman has the man does not have an equal
Choice therefore I think if we have more
choices we should take more of the
responsibility and say it is more of our
fault yeah because as a woman you
obviously have all those options but
then you shouldn't Lie To The Man I
agree with you I agree but so I I'm
doing a divorce documentary where I
interview men that have been like
wrecked in divorced right so this is a
whole like you literally wouldn't know
about this Rabbit Hole unless you're in
it but then essentially what happens is
um the men get married and a lot of
times it's the same system women are
usually between the ages of 25 and like
32 or 33 and what they'll do is they
want kids so they lie about being on
birth control to get the guy to marry
them because they know he's a good guy
and he'll do it and I mean I I guess we
don't know that they were lying yeah but
when you when you put it into oh I
forgot about this choice too you can
also track when you're ovulating you can
actually yeah you can only get pregnant
like five days a month I always look at
that and I'm like okay if I do have
someone I'm like no not there so even
though there's an excuse that I hear
about oh I don't want to go on birth
control because of my body yeah I don't
want to go on it because it effed up my
body correct and I and I think women are
fair to say that yeah but but but the
issue is that like the men don't know
when you're ovulating so all these
accidental pregnancies yes especially
over the age of 25 like under 25 I even
think under like 23 we can we can say
you were stupid and young but oh yeah
you don't know by by being 26 27 years
you should know you should you should
you should know correct and you know but
this is why you know I think getting
married younger is like better for women
because you don't have to deal with all
the all this [__] yeah control yeah all
the Heartbreak yeah I've always said to
myself I wouldn't be mad by like 25 then
have kids at 28 and I'm like at this
point I'm like I've got three years two
and a half years how many dates do you
go on like proper date it's not my name
I've been on a few I've been singled out
for a year okay I would say I've been on
quite a few dates but it could be more
dates but I've had things that have
happened but one of them no could not
two situationships yeah yeah that's like
the new form of dates of situationships
yeah the recent one two could not stop
texting me five minutes but I didn't
reply to him after five minutes even
when he knew too clingy yeah where I was
by Sophia message my friends 10 phone
calls well yeah I would say don't do
that but but I will say if you want to
be married which is a traditional out
come yeah I don't think you'll get it
through situationships because those
aren't tradition you know those aren't
traditional they're not they're not and
I'm now like okay chill if someone comes
along and they treat me nice fine well I
also think that's another lie that we
tell women is that the right guy will
just come along yeah really why because
you know I I think when you're young
maybe but a lot of women in the dating
Market are are older right yes and so
you don't really have the same privilege
like you're you're a pretty girl he
might for you
for the average chick average chick it's
like is the right guy you know you kind
of you have to figure out what type of
guy you want where is he and put
yourself in the rooms that he's in yeah
I knew mine was not in Australia okay
okay so it's kind of like let's say you
want to date a banker so if I had a girl
come to me and this is I do this
sometimes because girls will buy
sessions with me right you know and and
what they'll do is they'll say and I'll
so we lay out like what type of guy do
you want and so maybe she wants to like
what type of job would he do okay you
won an engineer where is the biggest
engineering firm in your city can you go
get coffee can you live around there
yeah can you and you see then then you
start to run into the type of guys you
want and it happens more naturally but
you know we live in such an anti-social
world yeah and we're all in our
Apartments expecting that something to
happen how is it gonna happen we're at
home social media yeah or that's where
I've met quite a few cool yeah yeah
that's the number one way people are
meeting but the problem is a lot of
these guys are dm'ing a bunch of you
know yeah and that's the hard thing it's
like how can I get more of your
attention and you want me more than her
that's what we think well you know it is
you know goes back to like putting him
first yeah you know you know and there's
but but I do think it's a lie to women
when we say oh it'll they'll just come
to you they'll come to you if you have a
social life in real life but yeah but
most people don't we just enter you know
at home a lot of people are just at home
all that they're just working yeah yeah
thing is when a girl says oh I don't
need oh you don't need me it sounds like
I saw that was a tournament the other
thing men want to be needed yeah I know
that I've learned that yeah I'm like
okay I know how to yeah yeah you know
but I get it because obviously we want
reassurance as women yeah so the men
need the exact same thing correct yes
yes
it's not a negative but like it's not
she may be resting your face so she's
like oh my God okay but hold on let me
let me finish though let me finish it's
not a necessarily a negative if a woman
makes money but it's not like we
genuinely like it's very low on the
totem pole in terms of what makes a
woman attract whereas like a woman might
look at a guy who's like a doctor or an
attorney or someone who's making good
money and that will make him more
attractive for men it it really it
doesn't make you more attractive and I
would also say that that for women to
succeed in the corporate world you need
to take on certain personality traits
that are typically going to be a bit
more masculine you're going to probably
be not be viewed as as attractive
because of that usually pretty agreeable
when it comes to like negotiation like
the top like earning women are very then
and they play yeah because what are you
talking yeah they're very disagreeable
and they take on that like dominant role
but but most men want feminine women do
you see how she's like making fun of
them for telling her let's say they're
like yeah this is what we want imagine
if we said I want a guy that is
successful hard working yeah the guys
aren't like oh you want a guy that's
hard working you're insecure no it's
just preference yeah yeah at the end of
the day yeah and she's she's like making
fun of him for it
um a man that really wants a feminine
woman will bring the feminine woman out
of America
oh my gosh this is stupid
was like
[__] talking too much I'd be like I
should think about how much I was
talking you know what I'm saying we
don't want to have to check you though
okay we don't we want you to come okay
but I'm trying to be successful baby I'm
not trying to think about what a man
wants that's totally fine so that's
totally fine but if you are if you do
have that very domineering strong-headed
headstrong personality
[Laughter]
it's true
I'm speechless
I mean I personally want obviously a
strong man but I would consider myself
strong women I've grown over the year
and I would say I now have more of a pit
an opinion however I still do like sit
back and wait for the man's opinion more
yeah yeah yeah well I just think it's
funny how men will tell us to our face
what they want and we just won't listen
yeah yeah like this yeah deal with that
you're gonna need a guy that's so
dominant that he's almost
if a guy holds himself a certain way
you're gonna have a respect for him
where you want to be my question is like
why do they have to do that imagine if
Ben said I am gonna act feminine until a
woman brings the man out of me like
imagine if a guy said I am gonna wear
like ballet shoes and put on a dress
until the women Brandon I'm gonna say hi
guys until the women make me into a man
you think he's crazy right yeah but
women can do that and everyone's like
that doesn't make any sense makes no
sense you want to act like that's
submissive little whatever you call it
but see that's you're talking about
conditional femininity yeah so you're
only you're like in the work business if
I'm sitting here like oh yeah uh I guess
I'll take 16 an hour that's gonna go
very well for me whether what when I
could just come up I swear I swear all
the women that talk about being
masculine at work have the most mediocre
jobs it's always like like lady you make
22 an hour in HR do you work in HR I
mean I I don't think she does but no I
just can't imagine she has like a high
power like she might work in
entertainment maybe but in a bank or
like a financial advisor stuff like that
yeah exactly but you would be surprised
though because I had someone come into
my work but then my boss was like why
would this woman choose this job
basically her dad's in the field oh I
would say it could be I mean there's
Basics yeah yeah
of 25 an hour and this is why that's
gonna give me more money maybe it won't
give me a gigantic range of men that
want me in a swimming pool but swimming
pool what can you handle you know hey
that's that's totally fine that's
totally fine like but there's many women
I think like that be ambitious that's
fine yeah but don't be crying at 40. I
wouldn't but if if you're bringing that
same sort of attitude to the
relationship it could be it could come
to the detriment of the relationship it
might be harder for you to secure a guy
because men we don't want loud
we don't want that we want calm we want
peace yeah we don't want we don't want
to contend with a woman we don't want to
contend with our girlfriend I mean why
it should be it should be a group thing
like you guys should be going to get
there why does it happen no but this is
it's like men improve for us all of the
time men will try to make more money to
get women yeah they'll try to go to the
gym to get women but women we never it's
like they tell us what we want what they
want and we don't like she won't listen
no and it doesn't mean you're a bad
person but it just means you know you
might need to improve in some areas of
your life yeah just mental yeah oh we're
butting heads because you're speaking
your opinion highly ambitious and
successful career women tend to be more
disagreeable yeah I know one you said
that
[Laughter]
she just says that how it is no I mean
like what's her job same as me the
answer actor so familiar yeah okay
that's totally fine okay that's totally
fine yeah like get your money I don't
think that those women are necessarily
going to be lonely they are they are
they tend to be look sorry hope they
tend to be all right well you should
bring your next show yeah hype you're
gonna come next yeah we should bring her
I don't think they're necessarily going
to be like I mean she might have to just
how a man is gonna have to build him
just maybe do you might have to turn it
back to find a guy that can understand
that she's actually soft but making sure
she gets what she oh yeah I mean and
then there's men that are so naive and
slow that they think that she's acting
like this because better than everybody
or whatever the case may be it's like no
she's acting like this because she she
maybe was raised by a group of women
right who have to be strong and
independent didn't have to work hard for
themselves and they have to say what
they need or what they want and if
you're gonna sit here and base off me
because I wasn't built up in a [__]
two pair at home with a man and a woman
like I don't know there's so many
scenarios where it's just you know my
question is whenever I hear girls talk
about being in single parent homes I I
have a lot of empathy right how would
you know how to be a wife if you never
saw one a lot of empathy yeah but my
question is are you sure if you want to
be married are you surrounding
yourselves by wives are you befriending
women that are wives and if you're not I
I kind of I I lack sympathy because
you're not taking the steps to become a
wife if that's what you want to be if
like if you want to be a dancer you have
to go to dance class right yeah
how do you become a wife if you don't
hang out with people that are already
yeah or like take lessons from wives you
know you can you can do that you can
there's a lot of women that have a lot
to say about being wives go parent home
and she grew up with all her and they
were just taught to okay all right all
right all right all right okay but do
you see what I'm saying I need to get
that for the show I need to get a violin
yeah I used to play violin I'll get you
in the back just whenever people start
telling me they're SOB stories I just
need like
just like go the world doesn't care
about your problems we all have problems
we all got issues the world does not
care no some have more issues than the
other but that's just how you deal with
it yes no or yes yes
yeah so what what did you think of the
have you seen this podcast before no
never that's so crazy it's so crazy to
me because these podcasts are everywhere
on my timeline so it's like so crazy
that you go through your life you don't
even see these yeah it's just like
obviously videos that I'll see you have
no clue yeah what I say yeah well who's
you who do you see the most on your
timeline also on Tick Tock it's more
like there's a lot of guys that do like
thirst traps
um a lot of dances and a lot of tarot
card readings do you believe in that
stuff I do yes oh dear yeah I know
there's a situation basically my dad
passed when I was 15. so that's why I
became spiritual why spiritual why not
religious I don't know I feel like I I
am religious in a way like I do believe
that's something there yeah and I do
believe the spirit's like there's
something after life I find that
spiritual people want the benefits of
religion but without the rules so they
want the like they want to feel close
with God they want like the the
community aspects but they don't want
the rules that come with religion what
do you mean like that well like if um if
I'm Catholic right yeah no I'm not I'm
not a dog I'm a bad Catholic okay okay
I'm Catholic they're like you're not a
real Catholic yeah I'm Anglican yeah I
don't actually know what that is it's
similar to Christianity but okay
basically the reason why angle Clinic
exists that's what I got told is because
there was this guy who had this
girlfriend but couldn't sleep with her
before marriage because Christianity
okay you can't sleep
because he couldn't do that so he then
created the Anglican church and that's
why that exists okay so Catholics if I
want to be a Catholic I have to if I say
I believe in Catholicism that I have to
follow Catholicism rules right yes that
means church on Sunday yeah confession
once a week
um that means
um I believe in the Trinity that means
that reading your Bible that means going
to church on Sunday and and all of that
requires work and effort yeah it does I
went to a Catholic School okay so I know
I sat there and I'm just like it's very
but that's what I mean it's like people
want the benefits when I hear spiritual
I hear the benefits of religion without
the cost so I want to feel close with
God but I don't want to go to church
right and you can correct me if you
think I'm wrong I want no I get it I
want like all of the benefits that come
with it but without any of the work that
goes into it yeah I get that I
understand that yeah so where do you
think I'm wrong in some aspects no
definitely not okay I'm just curious
just because I I wouldn't say I'm
spiritual I'd say I'm Catholic yeah so
I'm just coming from someone that says
they're spiritual like what what does
that mean I just believe that when you
pass there's another side and people
there's signs of as I say from God yeah
from your past to a loved one leaving
your science for you to work out and
follow okay so you think you get like
messages from your dad yeah all right I
put this I could even I think I can
believe that as a Catholic I don't
actually know I think we could we
believe in ain't do we believe in angels
I don't know he wants to do resets
I'm a bad Catholic I don't know what
they want me to say you're like oh you
know a bad one but you shouldn't drink
apparently as well I really I'm I'm not
a big drinker that's a good thing I
drink I can't even remember the last
time I drank Maybe
I'm not I I think we could drink no we
drink wine at Mass we just can't get
drunk yeah no you you do yeah and you
have bread or something like that yeah
yeah I don't even remember that I
remember I was at school and I couldn't
I wasn't allowed to take about a glass
of wine in America two months ago a
month ago a month and a half but before
that it was like four months it was a
while that's a long time yeah I can't
relate you know you know I am young
though so you are young
um but let me let me know what you guys
think in the comments
um you know this is fun I like I like
red pilling you um let them know where
they can find you uh my Instagram is
Sophia K Kate with an extra e on the end
of Kate so that's
s-o-p-h-i-a-k-a-t-a-e and my Tick Tock
is the Sophia Kate well guys like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time